estamos en el problema 21 nos dicen esta
es la solución de juan a una ecuación no
le he revisado aún pero nos preguntan
cuál enunciado relacionado con la
solución de juan es verdadero revisemos
la solución y veamos si le hizo bien o
tuvo un error veamos como la hizo y creo
que lo mejor es que la hagamos nosotros
la ecuación es n + 8 que multiplica a n
20 es igual a 110 lo primero que vamos a
hacer es distribuir este 8
multiplicándolo por n 20 no podemos
empezar con esta suma tenemos que seguir
el orden de las operaciones así es que
hagamos esta multiplicación primero
tenemos entonces n + 8 por n + 8 por 20
160 y esto que es igual a 110 8 por n 8
n 8 por 20 160 y aquí al ver su
desarrollo y el nuestro me doy cuenta
que hay un error está en e coincide
también coincide 8 n pero él no hizo 8
por 20 no hizo bien la distribución 8
por 20 son 160 no 20 como él tiene aquí
así es
y es 160 así es que juan cometió un
error en el paso 1 ya no tenemos que
revisar los demás pasos todo va a estar
mal después de ese error problema 22
cuando es verdadero el siguiente
enunciado el opuesto de un número es
menor que el número original el opuesto
de un número es menor que el número
original
veamos si el número es negativo el
opuesto del número va a ser positivo el
cual no va a ser menor a ese número pero
si el número es positivo su opuesto es
negativo el cual es menor al número de
acuerdo a un número negativo es menor a
un número positivo o equivalentemente si
x es mayor que 0 entonces menos x es
menor que x si x es positivo entonces
definitivamente menos 3 es menor que 3
así es que el enunciado es verdadero
para números positivos la respuesta hace
la respuesta a el enunciado nunca es
verdadero es falsa ya vimos que si se
puede cumplir menos 3 y 3 es un ejemplo
la respuesta del enunciado siempre es
verdadero también es falsa -3 su opuesto
es 3 que es mayor
a menos 3 y de el enunciado es verdadero
para números negativos no con el mismo
ejemplo menos 3 supuesto es 3 que es
mayor a el problema 23
cuál es la ordenada el origen de la
gráfica de déjame ver 23 nos dan la
ecuación 4 x 2 igual a 12
si nosotros graficar amos esta ecuación
la ordenada al origen es el punto donde
la recta intercepta el eje y ese punto
que tenemos ahí la coordenada n de ese
punto y esa intersección se da cuando la
coordenada en x es igual a 0 de acuerdo
así es que la coordenada ese punto va a
ser cero coma la ordenada al origen así
es que lo más fácil es a partir de la
ecuación ver cuánto vale que cuando x
vale 0 así es que cuando x es igual a 0
4x se hace 0 y nos queda 2 es igual a 12
de donde ya es igual a 6 la respuesta es
la opción se lo único que queremos saber
es cuando x es igual a 0
donde se intercepta la recta con el eje
y esa es la ordenada al origen siguiente
problema bien aquí nos dan una gráfica
nos dicen déjame copiar y pegar esto
bien
copiar
y pegar
ahí lo tenemos cuál desigualdad se
muestra en la gráfica de abajo para
empezar encontremos la ecuación de esta
recta de aquí aquí vemos que la ordenada
al origen es cuándo x es igual a 0 y es
igual a menos 1 recordemos que para
poner la ecuación de una recta en su
forma pendiente ordenada esta es de
igual a mx + b donde m es la pendiente y
b la ordenada al origen aquí cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a menos 1 así es
que el orden al origen es igual a menos
así es que b es igual a menos 1 tenemos
ahora que es igual a mx menos uno nos
hace falta entonces encontrar la
pendiente y la pendiente es cómo cambia
conforme cambia x vamos a calcularlo
entonces queremos calcular el cambio en
y dado el cambio en x y que tenemos
vemos en la gráfica que cuando x cambia
dos unidades que cambia una unidad es
decir que cambia una unidad cada x
cambia dos unidades también podríamos
haber calculado
x cambia cuatro unidades que cambia en
dos unidades
esto también es igual a dos cuartos que
es igual a un medio en fin ya conocemos
la pendiente que es el cambio en y entre
el cambio en x por lo cual la ecuación
de la recta es igual a un medio de x
menos 1 esa es la ecuación de esta recta
pero lo que nos están preguntando es la
ecuación de la desigualdad para empezar
en la región sombreada están incluyendo
la recta aquí está marcada la región
gris y la recta está marcada con una
línea continua si lo hubieran trazado
con una línea punteada entonces la recta
no estaría incluida en la desigualdad es
decir la desigualdad es mayor o igual o
menor igual pues se incluye la recta en
este problema las opciones son
mayor o igual a un medio de x1 o menor o
igual a un medio de x menos 1 veamos qué
pasa para una x dada por ejemplo cuando
x es igual a 2 si x es igual a 2 y lo
sustituimos en esta expresión obtenemos
ya igual a 0 es este punto sobre la
recta entonces para los puntos que se
encuentran en esta zona gris para ese
valor de x los valores de ye son mayores
que 0 o son menores que 0 claramente los
valores de ye son mayores que 0 son los
valores de iu que se encuentran por
arriba de los valores de ye que están
determinados por esta ecuación así es
que la desigualdad que representa la
zona gris que tenemos en la gráfica es
esta desigualdad que tenemos aquí y es
muy fácil tomar la decisión a ojo dado
que estamos incluyendo la recta el signo
va a ser mayor o igual o menor o igual y
como la zona sombreada se encuentra por
arriba de la recta entonces la
desigualdad es mayor o igual y esa es la
opción
opción de siguiente problema problema 25
este es otro problema en el cual
necesitamos copiar y pegar
bien aquí lo tenemos
cuál representa mejor la gráfica de ye
igual a 2 x 2 entonces sus pendientes 2
2 positivo y su ordenada el origen es
menos 2 a simple vista podemos
identificar la ordenada al origen en
esta gráfica la ordenada al origen es
menos 2 en esta gráfica también es menos
2 en las dos gráficas de abajo la
ordenada al origen es 2 positiva aquí la
tenemos ordenada al origen 2 así que
sabemos que el orden al origen es menos
2 books a donde se fue
aquí está
sabemos que la solución es una de estas
dos gráficas
tenemos que determinar cuál de estas dos
tiene una pendiente positiva de 2 en la
gráfica a cuando avanzó 2 a la derecha
avanzó 4 hacia arriba
el cambio en g sobre el cambio en x es
igual a avanzó 4 hacia arriba mientras
avanzo 2 a la derecha avanzó 4 hacia
arriba cuando avanzó 2 a la derecha si
es que la pendiente es 2 así es que esta
recta tiene pendiente 2 la respuesta es
ah y aunque la opción c no es la
correcta
analicemos cuánto vale la pendiente de
esta recta
ubiquémonos en un punto arbitrario por
ejemplo este d ya igual a menos 2 si
avanzó 2 a la derecha qué pasa con la y
aumenta su valor o disminuye su valor en
este caso la y está disminuyendo su
valor está disminuyendo en 4 es decir
que aquí tenemos que el cambio en y
sobre el cambio en x es igual cuando
avanzamos
positivo para la equis en que vamos a
disminuir en 4 por lo que la pendiente
es menos 2 está silver que una recta
tiene pendiente negativa cuando va
bajando de izquierda a derecha pero
siempre puede ser estas flechas donde
ves que al haber un avance hacia la
derecha hay una disminución hacia abajo
por lo cual la pendiente es negativa así
es que para este problema la respuesta
es a siguiente problema nos están dando
otro problema de identificar la
desigualdad correspondiente a una región
sombreada de una gráfica son
interesantes afortunadamente siempre
podemos copiar y pegar
aquí lo tenemos nos preguntan cuál
desigualdad la región sombra de la
gráfica representa de nueva cuenta lo
mejor es encontrar para empezar la
ecuación de esta recta a simple vista
podemos determinar que la ordenada al
origen es 2 y ahora cuál es la pendiente
cuando x aumenta en 1 cuando x aumenta
en 1 y baja en 3 de baja en 3 tenemos
entonces que para esta recta la ordenada
al origen es 2 fue lo primero que
notamos y la pendiente es el cambio en g
sobre el cambio en x vimos que cuando x
avanza en 1 y baja en tres el cambio en
que va a ser menos 3 así es que la
pendiente es igual a menos 3 y la
ecuación de la recta es igual a menos 3
x más 2 igual a mx + b y si vemos las
opciones que tenemos bien están en una
forma ligeramente diferente a como está
la ecuación que obtuvimos pero vamos a
obtener la desigualdad
para empezar la desigualdad va a ser
mayor o igual o menor o igual incluimos
el igual pues la línea está comprendida
en la región para cualquier valor de x
por ejemplo cuando x es igual a 2 cuando
x es igual a 2 de acuerdo a esta
ecuación el valor de y es igual a menos
4 ahora estamos incluyendo en la región
los valores de ye que son mayores ese
valor o los valores de ye que son
menores ese valor aquí vemos que estamos
incluyendo los valores de ye que son
menores a ese valor así es que esta
región representa la desigualdad de
menor o igual a menos 3 x más 2 a simple
vista al ver que estos valores están por
debajo de la recta podemos determinar
que la desigualdad es menor o igual
incluimos el igual pues la recta está
comprendida en la región si fuera una
línea punteada sería estrictamente menor
pero como dijimos esta no es la forma en
la que están las respuestas aquí phusion
las xy las guías del mismo lado podemos
hacer eso sumando 3x ambos lados de la
desigualdad que nos da 3x más esto es
menor o igual que menos 3 x 3 x se
cancelan y nos queda simplemente 2 la
región sombreada
representa la desigualdad 3x y menor o
igual que 2 que es la opción a se me ha
acabado el tiempo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo